[Musique]
m
l'origine de la vidéo harry potter c'est
essentiellement la capacité à pouvoir la
faire parce que en fait lorsqu'on tourné
la vidéo rpg 3 lorsqu'on se balade et
qu'on trouvait nos scènes dans le
château avec mathieu bob l'insee
dans le château on s'était dit quand
même un ses châteaux si on voulait faire
une vidéo harry potter ben il serait
quand même pas mal face et du cou à
l'origine de la vidéo harry potter c'est
là c'est ce moment-là précis où on a
remarqué qu effectivement le château
serait particulièrement adapté pour une
vidéo harry potter en bretagne c'est
quand même beaucoup plus facile de faire
tout ce qui est médiéval fantasy magie
mystique les elfes les druides et les
celtes que de faire batman et gotham
city
et justement c'est pour ça que six mois
avant la vidéo harry potter quand on a
commencé réellement la pré prod
exactement celle l'ont pas avant c'est
là où on a contacté la mairie pour donc
pour leur demander ce que vous seriez
d'accord éventuellement si on pouvait
tourner dans le château et la mairie et
le château de fougères ont gentiment
accepté et on leur promet on les
remercie énormément parce que si on veut
d'ailleurs pas une vidéo quoi
et oui je me et peut-être que tu te
demande d'où vient ce château eh bien
nous sommes ici au coeur du système
défensif breton intitulé les marches de
bretagne et qui protégeait les
frontières du duché de bretagne contre
celle du royaume de france
il ya eu plusieurs batailles importantes
qui se sont déroulés ici notamment entre
le duché de bretagne et le royaume de
france mais la plus importante de tout
c'était en 1166 lorsque le roi
d'angleterre henri plantagenêt numéro 2
est venu rasé intégralement le château
de fougères qui n'était constitué que de
bois à l'époque le propriétaire du
château qui s'appelait raul numéro 2
s'est dit avait quand même le bois c'est
pas terrible ça brûle un peu facilement
je peux être confirmée château avec des
pierres moi et c'est comme ça que le
château de fougères est sorti du sol
mais tout ce que je te raconte c'est
dans le parcours scénographique qu'on
peut trouver dans les tours allez suis
moi on est juste à côté de la salle de
banquet on va aller voir si humble
bundle d'or est toujours là et nous y
voilà nous sommes dans la salle de
banquet c'est dans cette salle et c'est
sur cette table qui était assis humble
bundle d'or ainsi que tous les
professeurs devant tous les élèves qui
étaient réunis ici
d'ailleurs pour la petite anecdote ça
n'est pas vraiment une salle de banquet
puisque ce que vous voyez là n'est que
de la décoration qui a été mis par le
château de fougères pour faire joli en
réalité nous sommes ici dans une salle
des gardes et la tour tout entière était
en réalité une tour d'artillerie qui
servait à se défendre et à tirer au
canon sur d'éventuels attaquants et
d'ailleurs si vous voulez quelques
anecdotes sur cette salle et sur le
tournage sachez que si vous regardez
bien dans la vidéo il y avait de la
lumière ici c'est parce qu'en réalité il
y avait un technicien qui était couché
pendant toutes les scènes et qui agitait
un spot de lumière pour faire croire
qu'il y avait un feu de cheminée est
d'ailleurs une autre anecdote de
tournage c'est que dans cette salle de
banquet il y a une immense armoire
électrique juste à côté de la porte
d'entrée
donc pour les techniciens croyez moi
c'était assez dur de ne pas la filmer et
enfin une dernière anecdote concernant
cette salle vous vous souvenez de la
bataille de nourriture à la fin où tout
le monde se jette des chips des pop corn
et c est bien on a eu un gros accident
sur cette scène puisque en réalité on a
laissé les pop corn et les chips traîner
un peu trop longtemps avant de les
nettoyer et le temps collée nettoie le
gras des chips et des pop corn avait
coulé sur le parquet ce qu'ils avaient
fait des tâches immonde absolument
partout heureusement maintenant le bois
la absorber on a eu chaud
[Musique]
nous sommes ici dans la cour du château
à l'endroit où ont été filmés la plupart
des scènes extérieures de la vidéo est
sur ma droite cet endroit avec tous ces
pilotes c'était l'ancienne salle de
banquet du château l'endroit où se
réunissaient les barons de faugères pour
venir festoyer et c'est également là que
nous avons filmé le cours de ballet
d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote il y avait
également un technicien par terre qui
jeté le ballon en l'air et c'est comme
ça que la dame dans la vidéo a pu le
rattraper
si vous vous demandez pourquoi
l'intérieur du château et détruit comme
ça et bien en réalité ce n'est pas parce
qu'il a été bombardée au brûlé no 1
incendie ou attaqués par le roi de
france dieu sait qui et bien non en
réalité c'est simplement parce que le
propriétaire du château au début du 19e
s'est simplement dit qu'il allait tout
démonté pour vendre les pierres et
d'ailleurs ce château ça n'est pas qu'un
simple lieu de visite c'est également un
lieu où il se passe plein de choses tout
au long de l'année il y à des spectacles
en été il ya des fêtes médiévales et des
ateliers un peu tout le temps et oui
effectivement vous avez raison c'est
évident je suis en train de leur faire
de la pub mais avec ce que le château de
fougères et la mairie ont fait pour nous
pour cette vidéo harry potter mais très
franchement on l'aura bien ça alors
comment on s'y est pris je pense que la
pré prod a commencé je disais six mois
mais en réalité c'était six mois pour la
réflexion et on est rentré dans la phase
active de pré prod quatre mois avant
mais ça
shon pourra mieux vous en parlais que
moi il fallait ni qui il fallait juste
nique et j'avais fait plusieurs mois
avant un tournage avec l'équipe de
warren flamel donc c'est tout ce qui est
quentin charlotte malo tu t'es laissé
très bien j'ai déjà il connaissait harry
potter il savait tout le il connaît ce
système de la débrouille donc c'était
vraiment les gens à avoir sur le
tournage alors évidemment on voulait
avoir une grosse équipe parce que parce
que le projet était un peu pharaonique
c'est à dire voilà c'était impossible de
faire ça à trois c'est à dire avec nico
fred et moi donc trois personnes pour
faire de la figuration et de la
technique et de et de tous voilà trop de
choses à faire donc il fallait des gens
et des gens qualifiés en plus une fois
qu'on avait cette équipe pour vraiment
gérer le cadre il fallait aussi une
équipe pour gérer des figurants parce
que après avoir fait un long casting
avec des cv avec plein plein de demandes
leur demander de ramener des costumes il
fallait vraiment organiser tout ça il
fallait que ce soit stricte et relax à
la fois donc c'était très très difficile
de jongler avec ça donc on a aussi
castet une équipe de personnes qui
étaient capables de gérer une foule est
surtout là ça a été vraiment un point
qui était important il nous fallait un
chef de sécu et damien s'est proposé
donc on a pu embarquer directement dans
les voitures dont c'était super pratique
on ne tourne jamais autant l'avancé la
vidéo qu'on a le plus tourné qu'on a le
plus organisé à l'avance habituellement
sur nos vidéos n'est sûr de délais de on
est sur des délais mensuel donc encore
la vidéo sort le 31
c'est qu'on a commencé à la beauce et
genre le 2 ou le 3 du mois donc
évidemment sur des délais aussi courts
si on était allé voir la mairie jambes
ont alors demandé à ce qu'on peut
tourner dans votre château dans des
jours ils nous auraient libre donc ça a
été ça a été complexe essais et c'est
gratifiant et en même temps extrêmement
fatigant
[Musique]
alors concernant les guest il était pas
je vais pas cirer les pompes mais
globalement ils ont tous été impeccables
sont des gens qui ont déjà tourné avec
nous dans la vidéo rpg 3 et du coup bas
pour nous c'était évident de les faire
revenir
surtout que bob il était fait pour le
rôle de guide aux rôles aux cartes
bonjour je suis par nab et arnaud
balthazar de la bavière mais d'un sans
doute déjà vu dans des productions
parisiennes
incroyable disons des oeuvres toujours
très éclairé et elle avait dans le
domaine du cinéma
ce qui m'intéressait dans le rôle de
l'orénoque dans la traduction officielle
bien sûr celle approche du personnage la
connexion instantanée que j'ai eue avec
lui
cette espèce de fraude qui l'incarnent
j'ai eu une projection personnelle dans
le personnage tout de suite quand on m'a
proposé le rôle mais voilà quelque part
ça m'a permis un petit peu de me
rapprocher de moi même et de faire une
communion avec l'ocs
mais quel esprit l'image que souhaite
obtenir cette production incroyable ça
fait plaisir à voir mr et mme b aussi
sur le tournage de puissants qu'on
voulait la voir et puis je sais par un
professeur rogue like ça veut dire ça le
salut correspondait tellement c'est ce
côté un peu filou c'est le meilleur mot
qui m'est venue en tête mais il jouait
super bien alors que pourtant ils
avaient peur de ne pas réussir à faire
deux à faire ce genre d'exercice est ce
qu'il ne fait pas souvent qui pris
beaucoup de plaisir à jouer mon
personnage même s'il savait que moi je
suis très dans la profitation le
spontané la répartie donc là j'étais un
peu timide au début pour jouer lear
montech jouer mon texte on a desserré
écrire quelques lignes ce qui est cool
links on voulait absolument l'humilier
aussi comme on a fait déjà dans la vidéo
rpg 3 parce que c'est notre petite
tradition un peu d'humilier links dans
les vidéos je suis déjà parus dans une
jdg sur les rpg 3 où je jouais déjà un
rôle de qu'on la joue moins drôle de
conte plus un rôle de pervers c'est ceci
joue pas pareil c'est une différente
approche du petit comédien finalement il
était à fond dans son rôle et puis et
puis même une liche joué très très bien
de souligner que peu de gens le savent
mais je crois qu'il a fait du théâtre du
théâtre d'improvisation je crois bruce
le truc c'est que bruce correspond à
fond par rapport aux rôles qu'on lui a
quant à lui attribué mais au fond lui là
il avait il avait cet énorme regret de
ne pas être en costume il était un peu
jaloux quand on était sur le tournage
parce que quand il regardait tout le
monde tout le monde même même links en
fait avec son son rôle un peu bizarre de
gérard swapo il avait quand même un
choix et un costume enfin il était dans
l'ambiance
harry potter et bosses il était en mode
je suis grosse de la chaîne y penser et
c'est tout et je casse une baguette
parce que je suis un peu je suis un vrai
prof de sciences voilà il aurait bien
aimé porter une robe un truc
enfin une tenue comme celle de bob qui
est une des plus réussies se trouve en
plus et puis la mienne aussi très bien
fait avec moi continuons mais pas dit
qu'il ferait mois qu'on mettrait dans la
boue je pensais que j'avais un vrai rôle
de composition du jury qui pensait
franchement
du froid il était parfait c'est vraiment
été parfait dans son rôle c'est tout le
monde l'attendait en harry potter
finalement il était là en hermione mais
il était parfait il éveille la vraie il
a tout donné comment il s'est il est
devenu une femme en train pendant trois
jours il a même créé un compte installer
un faux compte instagram texas granger
il était à fond dans son rôle et il a
d'ailleurs il est intervenu d'ailleurs
sur le script puisqu'il a rajouté pas
mal de ses répliques
il voulait vraiment maître de lui-même
dans son personnage donc vraiment il csu
s'est énormément investi dans dans le
script et des aidants son personnage est
vraiment excité super chouette de
l'avoir vraiment trop content ah oui là
je suis fabulous il faut vraiment qu'il
faut juste que je me choque pas si
jamais un moment donné il va entamer une
transformation il sera pas au top mais
il est crédible
dutra la mer
tout le monde est intervenue à un moment
ou un autre dans son personnage ou dans
ses lignes de dialogues pour les
retoucher pour ça s'adapte mieux à son
propre rôle et à vrai dire même était
censé y en avoir beaucoup plus que ça
puisqu'il faut voir que pour l'anecdote
la scène avec cyprien
en réalité il devait y avoir tout un mur
rempli de petit caméo on avait contacté
plein monde et qui devait appareils
comme ça dans des cadres l'ordre lors
d'un espèce de travelling où on passait
on voyait donc plein de tableaux vivants
sauf que ça n'a pas été possible non
mais du coup on a zappé la scène et on
n'a gardé que le truc avec cyprien pour
l'ouverture de la porte qui ça a été
prévu était prévu depuis le début et je
pense que tout le monde tous les gays se
sont éclatés vraiment sur ce tournage
donc frais d amour vraiment laissé carte
blanche de a jusqu'à z que ce soit au
niveau des décors des costumes des
designs même au niveau des budgets comme
je n'étais pas certaine vraiment d'avoir
tous les personnages avoir tous les
plans j'ai vraiment établie pendant un
mois une liste de toutes les choses qui
pourrait être combien il faudrait en
budget combien temps il faudrait pour
pour tout réaliser je savais qu'un
moment donné je vais me retrouver au
pied du mur avec très peu de temps et
beaucoup beaucoup de détails à faire
parce que c'est ça les costumes les
costumes c'est énormément de détails
pour que ça rentre bien dans les et
costumes on ne voit pas les détails on
remarque l'absence de détails
je voulais
vraiment que chaque identité de
personnages reviennent sur un peu mais
les acteurs j'ai dû vraiment prévoir
chaque pièce comme si je vais décorer
quatre murs parents la scène de banquet
c'est vraiment que de la décoration de
fête s'y fait ça de chez action vraiment
à bab budget qu on a repeint pour que ce
soit joli essai de la nourriture qu'on
devait utiliser pour les figurants
derrière donc j'avais donné des
consignes les gars on ne touche pas à la
bouffe parce que les bananes les
clémentines sykes bien mais surtout vous
mangez pas évidemment à l'instant où on
ferait des salles sont arrivés ils ont
fait alors les bannières c'est vraiment
la chose qui m'a rendu complètement
cinglé sur ce tournage
fred et seb ont fait des jeux de mots en
rapport avec les consoles et les vraies
maisons harry potter dont on va leur
dire encore une fois pc relève et
playstation tout est normal
loiseau va très bien justement mais ces
règles loiseau va très bien avec claude
chouf donc la playstation qui est bleu
mai aps les stades aig c'est pas très
joli et le jumeau fonctionnait pas donc
on a un peu été laxiste sur le mot en
lui même une fois qu'on avait vraiment
ses jeux de mots c'est saurina qui a
fait les les logos elle a vraiment
essayé de tout reproduire les petits
détails les les courbes et c'est que
c'était vraiment
monstrueux qu'après il fallait hisser
les bannières et six mètres de tissu
c'est très lourd surtout qu'on avait pas
beaucoup d'axés puisque c'est un vieux
vieux château donc la grande bannière
noah on a descendu des chaînes de chaque
côté pour rattacher la bannière et tous
remontés et prier pour que ça fonctionne
et je pense que c'est vraiment le truc
qui m'a le plus traumatisé je faisais
des allers retours avec les mecs en eau
qui tirait comme des gros molosse et là
moi je faisais des allers retours en bas
en faisant on va tuer quelqu'un on va
tuer quelqu'un derrière il ya une pierre
qui a failli tomber sur malaurie
heureusement qu'on avait une équipe
technique et un temps aussi pour
installer tous les secteurs parce qu'on
a mis deux jours à tout installé dans le
château avant de pouvoir tourner et sans
l'équipe technique j'aurais pas réussi
[Musique]
alors comment se sont passées ces deux
jours et demi je vais pas mentir c'était
quand même un peu rude simple
physiquement et mentalement éprouvant
c'était très long parce que le premier
jour on a bossé je crois dont on est
arrivé à 7h du mat que terrestres nous
les acteurs on arrive à 7h du mat mais
il ya de la pré prod est arrivé avant
nous et on s'est arrêté et devait être
23h30 quelque chose comme ça donc on a
tourné
15h12 qu'un entre 12 et 15 heures je
crois dans la journée donc c'était fou
fou tout le monde était à bout à la fin
ils ouvrent ils pas commencé
le coach avait appelé sur le côté plein
de couverture je t'ai mis toute fraîche
tiacoh ça surtout énorme et surtout les
deux tournages je fini par dormir le
terrain ses concerts à l'idée que je me
fais en faire c'est juste le patois
l'insee avec un chapeau ridicule avec
par dessus mais devant ça marche c'est
de bouffer tous écoutent marc desbois de
douceur presque mignon non non chapeau
c'est un petit natcom quoi franchement
c'est moi c'est quoi comme si un petit
dodo
mais on doit rester là jusqu'au bout
celui du courage
la figuration comme un roc médias
n'oubliez pas moi je me sens vraiment
mieux que fausses et c'est reparti et
c'est vraiment très compliqué et en plus
évidemment il ya eu la pluie par dessus
ça qu'il ya quelqu'un tout ralenti mais
au final on a réussi à faire ce qu'on
voulait donc
donc c'est un miracle s'est déjà face à
ces les mots de charlotte qui était la
première assistante ne pas la citer
c'est quand elle a vu à la base le plan
de tournage le les storyboards il ya des
soirées bord ou encore une fois il faut
le noter ça n'arrive pas tout le temps
si j'ai déjà mes visites il existait
mais voilà on avait une quantité de
plants faire de saint nazaire dans un
enfin compressé sur deux jours et demi
c'était vraiment très tendu et on
pouvait pas se permettre de trop
déborder la pire chose qui aurait pu
arriver ça aurait été qu'on se dise ah
ben ça en tant pis et aaron va arrêter
parce que tout le monde est fatigué et
au final ben on n'aurait pas pu finir la
vidéo et la vidéo à serait pas sorti ça
aurait été juste la catastrophe mois
laurent dans les duels a tronqué on
aurait dû enlever deux morceaux entiers
de la vidéo et ça c'est là pour le coup
ça aurait été du gâchis à l'état pur on
aurait fait ça sur fond fait arrêter
pour rien en fait et c'est là où voilà
toute l'équipe technique a brillé pour
nous aider à accomplir ce challenge
et pour le coup franchement il était à
genoux mais au final enfin quand on voit
les images voilà les images parlent
d'elles mêmes ces tests et le défi est
complètement rempli j'avais un immense
plaisir pendant ce tournage c'est parce
que je pouvais vraiment faire l'acteur
et ça c'est chouette alors que seb lui
il était plutôt à la réelle c'est-à-dire
plutôt affaire à le cadre plus comme ça
marche et c'est moi je m'occupais plus
de la direction d'acteur c'est à dire ah
non ça tue le fond dans ce plus comme ça
essayer de monter plus haut plus grave
mais plus de forme dans la voix
[Musique]
on fait du dossier
mais que fera sans eux mêmes en baisse
de 3 2 1
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc ce bail avec la baby toujours la
banane et en même temps et en heure
et vous moi je suis très content de ce
sénat enfin en tout cas de la partie
fiction qu on a greffé par dessus je
trouve qu'il ya une vraie cohérence dans
l'idiotie enfin je sais pas comment dire
ça mais il ya des gags absurdes mais qui
sont cohérents dans le monde qu'on
essaye d'établir en fait tout est fluide
tu comprends tout qu'il ya même des gags
en arrière-plan qui font qu après
plusieurs visionnages
tu peux tu peux les distinguer il est
remarqué faire ils ont mis un petit truc
là et ça c'est sympa et puis ça ça veut
dire ça donc au vert je suis très très
content du script je trouve que c'est un
des meilleurs scripts et ça tombe bien
parce qu'on a eu la meilleure image donc
tout s'est embrasé parfaitement c'était
chouette
j'avais peur aussi au début parce que je
m'étais dis à mes fins les gens les
aiment pas qu'un être mise en scène il
faut pas qu'on dépasse le ratio de deux
tiers de mise en scène pour 1/3 2/3 de
test pour un tiers de mise en scène
or là c'est la première vidéo où il y
avait quasiment autant de mise en scène
que de tests moi je flippais aussi à
cause de ça c'était vraiment de la
nouveauté et c'est pareil la partie test
d'ailleurs je voulais au début m la
chemise la chemise jaune et j'ai benzaie
benzaie qui matent année pour dire mais
on s'en fout vas-y reste en harry potter
pendant tout le long
et c'est vrai que ça me faisait flipper
aussi parce que je n'arrête pas de me
dire oui mais non les gens se fait neuf
ans qu'on les habitue avant cette [ __ ]
de chemises jaunes or si on l'enlève bas
ils vont ils vont râler match et j'ai
vraiment hésité jusqu'aux dans la
dernière seconde j'ai hésité mais au
final on l'a on l'a fait sans et au
final les gens
concernant les conditions de tournage
des moyens mis en place moi j'étais un
peu bluffé parce que quand quentin et
thomas donc quand ils nous ont dit
qu'ils ramenaient du matos avec eux
qu'il nous faut plein de voitures par
les amateurs à les y emmener
je crois que c'est via la boîte de
quentin une boîte audiovisuelle qui nous
a permis d'avoir ce matos enfin je sais
plus dans les détails mais en tout cas
voilà on avait du vrai matos peau ce qui
fait qu'on avait une vraie lumière
classe et du coup de voir tout ça se
mettre en place
moi j'étais j'avais l'impression d'être
soit vrai temps mais voilà c'est un peu
péjoratif ce que je dis mais voilà on
n'avait pas l'habitude d'avoir autant de
moyens pour faire un gilet j'ai donc
c'était ultra confortables et surtout
que moi en plus
qui d'habitude gère un peu tout ça quand
tu vois les autres le faire pour toi etc
vous aidez moi j'étais ultra frustré en
fait
heureusement c'est pas habitués on a
rebasculé sur un tournage un peu plus
complexe à 3 juste après dans voilà
histoire de retrouver les marques jdg
mais meiway le confort absolu
alors concernant la scène de nuit
c'était compliqué parce que du coup on
voulait tourner un autre endroit en fait
mais le château est éclairée la nuit par
des éclairages de la ville et on ne peut
pas les éteindre depuis le château parce
que ça ne dépend pas du château ça
dépend de la ville donc en fait
l'endroit où on voulait tourner il ya un
méga spot orange de fou qui fait un
éclairage rasant absolument dégueulasse
donc on a dû changer au dernier moment
l'endroit de tournage on voilà obligé de
tout changer et de changer de spots et
finalement je suis content de cette
scène parce que on a dû se réadapter en
catastrophe on avait une journée de
tournage dans les jambes on était
vraiment crevé tout le monde ne pouvait
plus fred commencé à danser et chanter
donc conseillé là là c'est un peu c'est
le baromètre ainsi commence à chanter on
n'est pas bien j'en car ils sont
fatigués sont mauvaises humeurs moi je
deviens coupe le moof
en fait tu as tu sais qui arrivait du
séisme il se retourne comme ça voilà
c'était le chaos
donc il fallait boucler absolument et on
a réussi à tout bouclé et finalement je
trouve c'est une des plus belles scènes
de la vidéo parce que c'est la scène de
nuit avec tous les effets d'éclairage
donc voila encore heures q2
thomas et quand les figures ont
énormément apporté à la vidéo ils ont
été tous adorables et on avait été très
très stricte avec ed des bonnes a dit
attention on a beaucoup de choses à
tourner fait le bazar dans la salle qui
vous est réservé et de l'autre côté
quand on est sur le plateau ça doit être
très très carré sinon on peut pas
avancer du coup c'est un peu un vraiment
un peu dommage donc les gens ils ont été
vraiment aller coûte le matin on avait
fait un petit discours très mignon c'est
vous laisser les acteurs répéter leurs
textes
ne souriez pas la caméra soyez calme
discipliné sur le plateau si on doit
vous rappeler alors encore et encore
vous sortez du plateau vous revenez ici
vous louper la scène suivante vous
couper plusieurs cette taxe si vous avez
le droit de vous amuser quoi c'est ici
la party fun un jour l'un d'entre vous
nous casser les pieds on vous casse et
genou et dans les douves et c'est devenu
une blague en fait en permanence et on a
vraiment vraiment pu mettre une bonne
ambiance et ils l'ont fait de même en
fait pour l'instant ça se passe bien
séchage ce n'est quand même à temps dans
les vidéos encore une fois je leur dis
mais avec seb on se divise le boulot lui
montrent toutes les mises en scène moi
je monte toutes les parties test le défi
à réaliser pour moi sur cette partie
test c'était de rendre intéressant des
jeux vous n'y a pas grand chose à dire
les jeux harry potter mais globalement
ils sont tous très bien donc c'est
c'était c'était mon ma grande peur en
fait et je l' ai dit plusieurs fois à
ces aides pendant le montage ou pas la
vidéo est sorti je me suis dit oh [ __ ]
la mise en scène elle est géniale mais
alors la partie test qu'est ce qu'elle
est nulle
mais au final les gens les gens en
apprécier justement petite anecdote le
pire c'est quand on a sorti jdg suivant
du mois d'après et ensuite on est allé
en convention je sais plus si tu es en
belgique ou en suisse enfin bref et à
chaque fois les gens nous ne faisait que
nous parler de la vidéo harry potter
alors que la nouvelle venait de sortir
et on vient de sortir une vidéo non
harry potter trop bien harry potter
génial génial donc voilà donc voilà le
plébisciter total et ça a coûté la vie à
une vidéo un jdg qui est passée
inaperçue tapis pour lui je les aime
beaucoup
comme quoi ça nous ouvre effectivement
d'autres possibilités c'est là qu'on
voit qu'on pourrait effectivement
refaire ce genre de vidéos sur des jeux
qui sont pas forcément mauvais donc ben
tant mieux je veux souffle alors le défi
technique
c'est comme à chaque vidéo où il ya une
thématique c'est essayer de reproduire
le plus fidèlement les faits qu'on peut
retrouver dans la source originale c'est
à dire en l'occurrence ici ce harry
potter donc le truc qui est bien c'est
que on peut trouver des images des
effets sonores en fait tout est à peu
près trouvable sur internet mais au
niveau des sorts cdu un peux me
débrouiller donc j'ai regardé les films
j'ai fait des captures à chaque fois sur
les séquences de des changes de
sortilèges et pour essayer de reproduire
un maximum voilà les l'effet voulu est
d'ailleurs toute l'équipe en fait les
trois quarts de l'équipe de techniques
qui était sur le tournage phone web
séries en parallèle sur internet donc
c'est warren flamel c'est pour ça qu'ils
utilisent leur banque de sons des faits
d' harry potter
la vidéo donc c'est pour ça je leur fais
un petit coucou et un petit merci
c'était le défi le plus compliqué
surtout qu'ils avaient un plan j'avais
fait beaucoup le forcing pour le faire
sur le tournage c'était cette espèce de
plein de latéral mais qui dure deux
secondes à l'image mais qui m'a pris du
temps à faire parce que il ya un
sortilège qui part et c'est bob qui le
parle comme ça avec sa baguette donc
voila c'était un peu long à faire mais
je trouvais que ça aérer un peu la mise
en scène
si l'on sait que des champs contre
champs entre fred est bonne alors petite
anecdote par la croissance est vraiment
casser les pieds c'est qu'on a utilisé
un espèce de petit flash
on a vraiment synchroniser des mouvement
de baguettes faut vraiment avoir cet
effet de commandes de de lumière qui
réflète sur le corps et qui donc
vraiment vie à l'effet en fait au sort
et notamment c'est sylvain qui a
beaucoup aidé mais déjà et qu'il était
alité du courrier partout enfin il aider
au niveau de la technique de la lumière
de plein de domaines et nous a aidés à
faire ça ils étaient allongés lui aussi
dans l'herbe en train de faire ses
petits flashs donc on faisait des petits
des cours des comptes à rebours trois
deux un flash donc tac au québec que
j'étais en train d'étalonnage de aulas
après envie mais je crois que d'ailleurs
c'est une des premières scènes que sur
laquelle j'ai commencé à bosser et dès
que j'ai réussi à obtenir quelque chose
d'assez jolie en colo je l'avais fait
tourner à tout le monde quoi pour
rentrer à regarder a résolu ce qu'on a
fait c'est pas du caca c'est cool on l'a
pas fait sauter on a tous tourné donc ce
plan a été tournée il a été un peu
compliqué à faire mais au final je
trouve qu'il a r et il rend la scène
encore plus belle donc je suis très
content de ça parce qu'il ya vraiment
deux choses qui m'ont marqué pour les
costumes
c'est que benzia a quant lui a demandé
s'il voulait bien faire il a fait ok
mais c'est aurore qui s'occupe des
costumes et ça m'a juste trop touché
parce que j'ai vraiment cherché à avoir
une vraie belle perruque de cinéma pour
qu'il soit vraiment impeccable et la
deuxième attaque dot c'est vraiment le
chocolat chaud de bléneau enfin répété
talkie walkie à on a besoin de rohr pour
une urgence de costumes et moi j'étais
là bas c'est bon et un truc qui s'est
décousu c'est pas grave et oman j'arrive
je vois une tâche mais mais cammas mais
jusqu'au mas de cacao j'étais là ok j'ai
pris de vie des regards tantôt voix
d'aider des traces de fond dîner de rien
il faut regarder de près
cologna n'est qu'au sud elle est arrivée
et a refait la tête un camion
[Rires]
sauvez moi qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
je fais et c'est vraiment à l'eau
bouillante et aux frottements qu'on a eu
ça ils n'osaient plus rien faire ils
avaient peur d absolument tout mon
meilleur souvenir de cette vidéo j'ai
envie dire c'est les scènes de banquiers
parce que ce sont les scènes principales
c'est les scènes où il y avait le plus
de figurants en fait donc c'est vraiment
les scènes qui visuellement pour nous
les acteurs rendait vraiment bien même
quand on était dedans et puis c'est
chouette de voir les gens se balader
dans le château en uniforme d'harry
potter avec avec les différentes
couleurs match je trouve
je trouve que l'ambiance et l'ambiance
était coulé et ça rendait vraiment un
peu un peu magique le tournage aussi
donc moi c'était vraiment les scène de
banquet que que j'ai vraiment j'ai
vraiment kiffé
j'ai envie de dire équipe c'est grâce à
toute l'équipe technique aux figures a
en fait toutes les personnes qui avaient
autour c'est vraiment c'est tout un
ensemble qui a fait qu'on a pu la faire
arvid vraiment de leur dédicacer cette
vidéo parce que voilà c'est vraiment
leurs efforts à eux qui ont permis de
faire ça au final cette vidéo harry
potter c'est clairement pour moi la
meilleure vidéo qu'on est fait en termes
de prod
ça s'est bien passé et au final tout le
monde était super ravie de participer
on a fait des on a pu faire des photos
avec tout le monde à la fin les gens
c'est un super souvenir vraiment j'ai eu
aucun mauvais retours de la part des
figurants pour eux ça a été vraiment une
super expérience de pouvoir voir un
tournage de pouvoir discuter avec les
guest parce qu'évidemment les guest se
balader discuter un peu avec tout le
monde
donc c'était c'était bien géré et je le
dis à chaque fois mais c'était chouette
le tournage s'est si bien passé on s'est
marré ça a été l'occasion de revoir les
potes aussi très bonne expérience pour
le coup c'était fun
pour moi c'est un petit peu particulier
parce que joueur du grenier ça a été la
toute première chaîne youtube dont je
regarder des vidéos et donc moi quand
ils m'ont proposé de participer à ce
truc là j'étais évidemment ultra ravi et
fier et je n'avais pas du tout anticipé
à quel point c'était un gros machin moi
c'est jérôme henry et je joue le rôle de
hagrid dans cette vidéo du joueur du
grenier je m'attendais pas du tout à ça
je me suis beaucoup amusé et j'ai
beaucoup rigolé et on est content
d'avoir pu rencontrer tout ce beau monde
c'est tout c'est une combinaison c'est
l'équipe c'est les lieux c'est les
acteurs savent et guests et
c'est seydou même si le script à vis de
la france voilà non c'est tout c'est la
combinaison de tous ces éléments qui ont
fait que la vidéo elle est bien
rencontré un magicien de ta région
[Musique]
[Rires]
incendio et j'ai juste j'ai juste à dire
que si j'ai si j'étais en train de
dormir et justement ce parce que lui ruf
le batteur la nuit lui et moi quand je
ronfle les murs tremblent à ces ousmane
avait tu fais je suis francis ford
coppola
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas tourné a
refusé les coffrets
j'aime le minimalisme les noix annoncé
la représentation de la discipline
[Musique]
je suis étudiant neurones et de temps
mais j'ai pu s'éjecter ainsi qu'à moi
donc je peux ma maison de la disparue qq
les bonbons je te laisse à la vidéo et
ce que j'entends à celle assez dommage
que l'argent
oui pièces du puzzle deviennent plus
claires maintenant j'ai vécu une zone de
plus en plus non non je suis genre tu
sais qu'il ya tellement longtemps que ça
sente à la voir qui vous ce secteur là
maintenant en pleine lumière on se rend
compte que je me suis rasé à 7h15 ce
matin chez fred journaux [ __ ] des
années d'études et passeur de magie pour
changer la météo c'est de la merde de la
merde merde je suis fatigué j'ai des
rhumatismes n'y a pas de soi pour
contrer ça jj top
saluons concert à fougères le 14 août
est pas au stade de la partie qui
pêchent suspensif
non non mais c'est bon là j'ai fini là
c'est bon je suis venu j'ai tourné j'ai
mon chèque je me casse
beaucoup
donner une heure momboisse un petit peu
avec ton truc trop frais du visage asie
c'est sa revanche mais encore plus bas
et une dernière dernière une dernière
action je te tuerais prufer fois de
georges tu sais qui comme l'innovation
et leur ton peuple et non à l'envi ont
bien sûr on a un truc marrant les
pierrots barbares pouces ok ok je veux
bien je vais bien je sais qu'il faut
être gentil avec menu spécial merlin
monsieur cela dit je me suis éclaté
parce que j'étais du coup totalement à
contre-courant du truc mais c'est
toujours plaisant